Phát chị thì chừng chừng hoa yên làm là sẽ tương đưa với tăng chừng người ta khó
trong kỳ miệng lộ mởi thì tương đời là phùi mộ thì chừng tăng gấp lộ cho những cái mình thường
tâm ông mà mũn ngờ làm tới
Khi chỉ vọng tiếp tập tới vọng tròa 2 con xó lầm của làm khá tốt
Vũn đẹn đơn thang, liền tinh nhà đầu tư để mấy cái miệng mấy về mạch chính trị
cũng như cái mới là mấy cái mạch tên tế này
và chỉ vọng tăng trường là vọng lợng mất người chiến đồng chăm
và tư bình tòa nhiều gì khi vọng người chiến đồng chăm
Đó khi vọng là nằm ai pio của các thơ lục thứ nhìn mới,
sợ bởi ra các hội đồng tươi tươi nha đừng là
Lức ở tò
thì chụi lên thì kính xuống trong hẹn của tức mình thôi
Cái quang trong những đặc con một tầm dành gà hẹn, để mì
Đi có một cái rồi là
Chính kính là chúng ta cần đồng tươi với dịch
Xú mạng, tính buu, hòm vì dịch cả
Dạ ló khi thử chụi cái chụng đồng ló là
Bất chăng kinh tế, tính mạng, tối, tối, tính tế, tối, kinh hoán, tối là sẽ
Khi hệ hòa của uổi dịch CD-8,
trong năm 1 rồi là 3, 2 phải chính mình trong
Tình hình thôi không có kinh xuất là tính vào là nâng kỳ vòng
cái mức, tâm lắm và 1 chăm 1 năm, mấy chăm 2 rồi
Chỉ kinh xuất là tính vào là tính mất kỳ vòng
cái mức vừa phải là hòm
Hơn 1 năm, mấy chăm 1 năm trước bình
Các chì đầu thư và 1 cụ đồng tư mà chúng cũng kìa
chúng mình 1 năm dạ hấm tánh trưởng nằm 1 năm, chăm 1 năm
Tì sau năm năm, tính vào là dành bôi xuất hiện
Chán chì vào 1 hòm vào 1 tảy đi, tì sau năm năm, chán chì các được
2 tảy
Và sau 1 năm là chán chì các được bống tảy
Và sau 2 năm là chán chì các được
1 xấu tảy
Và sau 3 năm là chán chì 3, 2 tảy
Nếu mà con chì 3, 1 năm tảy đồng vào
Nếu nổ tư được bằng gà, thì 3, 3, 5, 6, 6, 6, 6, 6, 7, 6, 6, 6, 7
Thì như bạn có những định là lại xuất đánh cào
Thì có khó khăn cho các việc đồng tư và chế phía
Tính nhiên trong cái nguy mình của có thơ
Thì mà đồng tư cho phía nó không đơn thường là
Một xa đỏ mình để chết khán chạp phía vải
Để ím trong trong trong cái dân mục và mình bây giờ ăn hôm bất lợi về cái việc lại xuất tăng
Không về quí chúng tôi là phải quảng lý
Mà phải linh hoạch, có nghĩa là chúng tôi nhấn đình
Tình thình lại xuất tăng
Thì chúng tôi sẽ ghi tính các phản đầu tư của mình ngán hảnh hơn
Và chúng ta sẽ tái đầu tư nhấn trái
Chái phía khác, hảnh hảnh hảnh hảnh hảnh hết
Thế là xuất cào hơn để tố thử hóa
Thế vì đủ rồi chúng tôi bị khải xuất tăng
Và khi chái phía, xin lọc khi mà lại xuất mà đảnh có kế
Sù hướng là đỉnh thì chúng tôi lại chuyển mục
OK OK, đến một sàng những cái chế phía hảnh hơn để hướng lợi
Đầu việc chế phía giảm
Thì ngoài cái việc thu nhật
Có cái lại xuất cào
Thà mình đó là cái kèry nó cào
Mình còn cái lợi từ cái việc là các vị tổ gên
Còn cái việc lại xuất khi mình đầu tư với cái lại xuất cào
Thì chưa mất đầu là lại xuất giảm và giá cho phía nó sẽ tăng
Thì thần ra thêm tò nhận định thêm năm 2019
Nó sẽ là cái cơ hỏi
Thống và chúng tôi luôn sách sau trong tư việc là chuyển mục
Gây chế những cái cái dân một của người địa đẹp được cái là những tổ ra
Và mình tối thử quá các việc là chủ sò về lại xuất cào
Nếu mà bạn không phải là nhà đầu tư kinh nghiệp
Cũng như là bạn không có nhiều thời gian
Để tôi nghĩ là bạn, bạn, đầu tư kinh kỹ quảy
Thì tôi nghĩ là bạn nâng
Đầu tư kinh định và đầu tư đình kịh và nắm những lâu dài
Mở vì đó là thực hiện nếu mà bạn bởi vì phong tâm bởi những cái lợi quyền
Hả nâng bạn chăm ngồi lại, lời nâng ngồi chăm chốc lợi lợi lợi
Lời nụ chúc là mắn linh để mua lại sâu
Thì thực ra là khi bạn có thể có thể chí phía vui được bạn
Tình khá là nhiều
Thì tháng như là một trong trong nhau tư nè muốn là mua thấp bánh cào
Và...
Bánh cào một là thấp hơn
Trong trong, trong hòa liên hình chỉ thích trong
Tư nghiên tư nghĩ là...
Hơn chính mươi chính lòng trong nhau tư
Tư nè...
Bằng người phải
Túng tôi là thống kè giữ chân, kết à ta mà chúng tôi có được
Tư nắm mưa nghìn nhau tư khủ đình
Cũng có đi xí đe ít đi
Tư nắm có là
Tính lực
Nhìn chung là
Lần như là chúng tôi nể nhau tư là
Nên nắm giữ lâu dài
Và đau tư đình kì
Thì điều đó sẽ có thật
Chào các bạn hòa hay là chờ
Mùa là các bạn
Cây đi ninh tục